what is a better way to show someone you
love them than laying a big kiss on
their face but what else are you sharing
when you share a kiss with someone if
you were a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and give this video
a big thumbs up get your lips ready
because today we are discussing 15 crazy
facts about kissing you didn't know it
burns calories that's right
kissing your loved one can actually burn
calories in fact you can burn up to 2
calories in just a minute that means if
you want to ditch the gym then you need
to pucker up and make out with your
partner for 10 hours just try not to get
a facial muscle cramp in the process
origins of your kissing style did you
know that your style of kissing is
developed in the womb studies show that
most fetuses tilt their head to the
right while in the womb tilting your
head to the right is the most prevalent
kissing position which suggests that
fetuses are practicing this behavior
this means you've been practicing your
kissing technique since before you were
even born it saves lives
ladies if you want to keep your spouse
around for a while then studies suggest
you should kiss them goodbye in the
morning men who kiss their wives goodbye
before work can increase their life
expectancy up to 5 years so if your man
isn't into PDA let him know he's missing
out on kisses as well as time the
longest kiss ever when it comes to world
records the kissing world record seems
like time well-spent one couple in
Thailand made headlines in 2013 when
they broke the world record for longest
kiss by kissing for over two days in
fact a couple kissed for 58 hours 35
minutes and 58 seconds total
the lip-locking world champs beat the
previous title holders by over 27 hours
and 17 minutes your eyes dilate kissing
can do some pretty bizarre things to
your body one of the most bizarre things
kissing does is that it actually makes
your eyes dilate it is speculated that
this is the reason people usually kiss
with their eyes closed so don't feel bad
for not kissing your partner with your
eyes open
it's more natural not to the muscle
power it may not seem like it but you
use a lot of muscle power when smooching
your partner it takes 146 muscles to
execute a simple French kiss including
34 facial muscles and 112 postural
muscles if you want to use less muscle
power a simple
only uses two facial muscles this means
the more passionate the kiss the more
facial muscles are needed it has health
benefits considering kissing can be a
real mood booster it should be no
surprise that kissing has many health
benefits some of the health benefits
from kissing include strengthening your
immune system preventing cavities and
relieving aches and pains not only
should you kiss on love but now you
should also kiss free of health disease
transfer risk of course no good thing
comes without its risks and
unfortunately kissing does have its
risks the most common known diseases but
transfer from kissing as mono and herpes
simplex virus type 1 there is also a low
chance HIV can be transferred though it
has happened before due to a specific
situation
one hiv-positive man kissed a woman and
transferred HIV because they both had
gum disease which caused his blood to
exchange with hers during the kiss thus
giving the woman HIV the head tilts when
it comes to tilting your head when you
kiss
chances are you tilt your head to the
right a neuroscientist who studied 120
kisses over two and a half years found
that people are 2 times more likely to
tilt their head to the right instead of
the left this is probably for the best
since you don't want to bump your
partner's nose right before it kiss it's
not Universal while most of the world
used kisses as a form of physical
communication there are still cultures
that don't kiss in fact about 10% of the
world's population doesn't kiss at all
instead of locking lips these people
show their affection for one another by
licking or biting self-esteem plays a
part deciding whom you want to kiss may
depend on how you feel about yourself
studies have shown that when women have
higher self-esteem they're more picky
about who they choose to kiss when it
comes to men they are more selective
with women they kiss than women they
take to the bedroom first silver-screen
kiss it may be surprising but the same
guy who invented the light bulb also
reported the first-ever kiss on film in
1896 Thomas Edison reported a 23 second
long short film the kids that featured
nothing but two actors kissing one
another the film was quite scandalous
for the prudish Victorian era
how your brain reacts not only is
kissing good for your health but there
are also actual psychological changes
taking place when you kiss someone you
may start to crave more kisses from
someone because your dopamine levels
spike after a kiss dopamine is a
neurotransmitter that helps control the
brains pleasure centers and is also
spiked when an addict partakes in their
addiction you will also start releasing
the love hormone oxytocin which is
responsible for sudden feelings of
attachment humans aren't the only ones
who kiss there are several species of
animals besides humans that use kissing
to show affection though it may not be
exactly the way humans kids they still
mimic similar behaviors chimpanzees have
been known to demonstrate kiss like
behavior after a fight in a sort of kiss
and makeup manner even meerkats and
elephants have their own version of
kissing
meerkats use kiss like gestures to
determine dominance while elephants use
a form of kissing to console one another
during hard times microbe exchange when
you kiss your partner you're swapping
more than just saliva you are actually
swapping up to 80 million microbes
between the two of you research has
shown that if a couple kisses more than
nine times a day they will even share
similar bacterial makeup on their
tongues this brings new meaning to
what's mine is yours did you already
know some of these crazy facts about
kissing react in the comment section
below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to the things
[Music]